[Música]
bienvenidos a ella soy de france 24 en
kenia más del 65% de las niñas y
adolescentes en edad escolar no pueden
ir al colegio porque no tienen recursos
para comprar toallas sanitarias en este
contexto es imposible para ellos vivir
los días con normalidad durante su
periodo menstrual muchas terminan
dedicándose a la prostitución para poder
obtener dinero y así suplir una
necesidad de tan básica como comprar
toallas sanitarias otras usan material
de colchones y hasta la boñiga o xxi de
excrementos de las vacas están
constantemente expuestos a infecciones
que a veces son fatales y es que también
hay falta de acceso al sistema
hospitalario
me golpee que es una adolescente
colombiana que vive con su familia en
kenia esta joven de 17 años junto a
varias amigas y a su hermana creó la
organización freedom to flow para
concientizar sobre este grave problema
de las adolescentes en el país africano
su tarea es recolectar donaciones para
entregar toallas reutilizables a las
niñas en las escuelas
la menstruación es un proceso natural
más de la mitad de la población mundial
la experimentará una vez al mes durante
gran parte de su vida pero de unos 800
millones de mujeres que tenían la
menstruación cada día 500 millones no
tienen acceso a productos de higiene
menstrual una desigualdad que altera el
ritmo de vida de las mujeres y que una
vez más las deja en situación de
desventaja el problema se acentúa aún
más en los países africanos en kenia por
ejemplo dos de cada tres mujeres no
cuentan con los recursos para comprar
toallas higiénicas sin sus derechos
menstruales garantizados deben recurrir
a soluciones precarias como el uso de
materiales no aptos que pueden traer
infecciones en el peor de los casos se
quedan sin opciones para salir a la
calle y vivir una vida normal y así
también se vulneran otros derechos como
la educación la salud la libertad de
expresión
un grupo de estudiantes internacionales
de secundaria quieren generar impacto
social en nairobi me siento realmente
apasionada por resolver la pobreza
menstrual e intentar ayudar a estas
niñas por eso crearon la iniciativa
freedom to flow el 9 way y ccoo es una
forma a la que nos pueden ayudar es
donando ustedes sabían que con solo 8
dólares una niña puede obtener una
toalla reutilizable que puede durar 3
años y es conscientes de que al menos 65
por ciento de las niñas keniatas no
pueden pagar por toallas decidieron
iniciar una campaña de donaciones para
proporcionar almohadillas reutilizables
y distribuirlas en las escuelas locales
estos protectores menstruales pueden
durar hasta tres años son fáciles de
limpiar ahorran dinero y son ecológicos
y es que durante los mismos dos años que
podrían estar usando una toalla
sanitaria reutilizable la persona
promedio usa aproximadamente 480 toallas
higiénicas o tampones que terminan en la
basura
la tarea es con el medio ambiente y con
los derechos humanos el esfuerzo está
orientado a educar a las comunidades en
derechos sexuales higiene menstrual y
educación sexual para aliviar los
numerosos desafíos que plantea nacer
mujer en un mundo machista
me golpee que es una colombiana de 17
años en kenia y cofundadora de freedom
you tube flow en español
libertad para fluir libertad para
sangrar nicole bienvenida a ella soy y
quiero comenzar pidiéndole que nos hable
de su iniciativa cuanto han recolectado
y para cuántas niñas les alcanza al día
de hoy
hola entonces somos hemos recolectado
cuatro mil dólares entonces nosotros
compramos unos kits que se ven así estos
kits tienen como diez toallas reusables
que les dura a las niñas como 55 años
con estos con esta plata hemos podido
acoger por ahí sin 550 kits y estos kits
se los damos a cada niña y después a la
organización que estamos con que se
llama para armar
se nos da y también les educa sobre la
educación sexual
de higiene y cosas así
usted y yo somos mujeres en edad
menstrual y nos enfrentamos todos los
meses a la necesidad de conseguir
productos que nos ayuden a vivir esos
días con tranquilidad y permitirnos
estar integradas en nuestras actividades
sociales con total normalidad porque son
tan importantes estas toallas
reutilizables en una ciudad como nairobi
entonces aquí en nairobi
es muy importante porque las niñas
tienen que ir al colegio tienen que
tener una vida normal cuando les damos
estas tareas causales pueden tener esto
y no tienen que faltar el colegio no
tienen que prostituirse por ejemplo para
comprar estos toallas y esto es el
derecho a ir al colegio lo tenemos tanto
las mujeres tanto los hombres las
toallas higiénicas deben ser productos
de acceso básico y así ninguna niña
tiene que perder días de colegio
además de estas toallas reutilizables
ustedes nos comentaban cuando nos
hablaban de la iniciativa son hechas por
madres de las comunidades locales
entonces como están impactando
positivamente no solamente la vida de
las niñas que ahora van a poder asistir
al colegio sino de la comunidad en un
entorno de falta de derechos de falta
por ejemplo de servicios públicos y de
pobreza
si entonces esta organización también se
enfoca en mujeres que sean
que sea en experiencia do por ejemplo
abuso sexual y cosas así que pueden ser
difíciles conseguir trabajo después de
una experiencia así entonces esta
organización las ayuda con trabajo para
dinero para vivir para poder vivir
y les da esta oportunidad de poder
también ayudar a otras niñas en el
proceso y también obviamente ayudar a
las mujeres que en las comunidades
acerca donde están los colegios para
hacer estas tareas amplios hables
nicole usted ha vivido en eeuu ha vivido
en colombia ahora vive en kenia ha
vivido en sudáfrica y por eso quisiera
aprovechar para preguntarle cómo ha sido
su experiencia y su encuentro con otras
culturas
al hablar de salud reproductiva y de
salud menstrual porque la verdad es que
lo normal por ejemplo en los países
latinoamericanos es que el momento del
periodo menstrual ni siquiera se
menciona ni siquiera se utiliza la
palabra menstruación
sí entonces cuando yo vivía en estados
unidos yo tenía
yo me mudé cuando tenía como nueve años
yo estoy era muy chiquita no sabía mucho
sobre esto después fue más en suráfrica
cuando me dio
la atención de este problema entonces
con esta nota logrado yo tenía una clase
y nos estaban hablando sobre el abuso
sexual y nos dijeron de este tema
después me impactó bastante porque es un
tema que no sabía qué pasaba y que
afecta a muchísimas mujeres en todo el
mundo ni siquiera espera mente en áfrica
entonces quise investigar más y allí fue
cuando me involucré más en este tema y
después aquí me mudé aquí a kenny hace
cinco meses y me reuní con unos amigos y
amigas y empecé este servicio para poder
ayudar a estas niñas
no hay recursos para gestionar nuestra
menstruación claro hay casos extremos
como el que usted ha visto en nairobi en
el que las niñas ni siquiera tienen los
recursos para comprar una toalla
higiénica pero en general a las mujeres
no se nos facilita la adquisición de los
productos para cuidar de nuestra salud
menstrual y para garantizar nuestros
derechos menstruales los productos
sanitarios que utilizamos cada mes son
costosos esta es una realidad que se
vive aquí y que se vive allá donde usted
está
desafortunadamente las niñas de aquí no
tienen suficiente dinero para cogerlos
no solamente aquí otra vez en todo el
mundo las niñas no tienen suficiente
dinero para estos toallas entonces
con esta organización lo que me gusta es
que sean revisables entonces duran por
hora y cinco años así se ahorra dinero
no se tienen que gastar la plata en esto
en vez se lo pueden hacer para comida o
cosas así más
y no se tienen que preocupar de esto no
tienen que perder el colegio no se
tienen que precipitar
y quería preguntarle también por la
normalidad de lo que es ser un cuerpo
menstruante sangrar es normal debería
ser algo de lo que se habla con
tranquilidad no tendría que ser un tabú
ni mucho menos un lujo poder ir a la
tienda oa una farmacia a comprarse una
toalla sanitaria cuál es el mensaje de
la organización que usted está formando
con sus amigas y con su hermana sobre
normalizar la menstruación y los
derechos menstruales
si no hay testigos muy grandes sobre
sobre menstruación
en este servicio nos pusimos con hombres
y mujeres para también tratar de quitar
el sigma y en serio
todo para que todo el mundo pueda
[Música]
podamos ayudarnos juntos
otra vez el derecho ir al colegio lo
tenemos tanto las niñas tanto los
hombres es algo que no se debería
no seguiría ser un ser un factor porque
tenemos nuestros nuestros períodos
entonces queremos quitar este estigma
que se puede hablar normalmente que se
pueda ayudar a las niñas y es tener más
soporte desde el mundo entero
y ya para finalizar mi cole quiero
pedirle para nuestros televidentes que
nos dé la información de dónde podrían
contactarse si estuvieran interesados en
donar dinero o en apoyar la causa de
alguna otra manera cuáles son los
canales para hablar con ustedes
entonces nosotros tenemos una página
instagram al frente flow allí nos pueden
preguntar cualquier pregunta tenemos
nuestro
a nuestro golfo que es un sitio para
recaudar fondos siempre está abierto
y allí también ponemos bastante
información sobre pobreza menstrual
tenemos historias de las niñas tenemos a
estadísticas tenemos también a noticias
de que está pasando y entonces aquí es
un sitio muy bueno para
información y para afrontar lo que
quieran
nicole gracias por sus esfuerzos gracias
por su iniciativa y le deseamos desde
france24 mucho éxito recolectando ayuda
para quienes más lo necesitan gracias a
ustedes ya nuestros televidentes de por
ver una vez más ella soy de france 24
sigan con nosotros
[Música]